[Music]
[Music]
what is up what is good it is officially
week 12 Thanksgiving week we got three
games on Thursday we got a bunch of
games on Sunday 15 in total we're gonna
dive a little bit into sims's film we're
gonna make our pets for the week and you
may be wondering if you're watching on
YouTube why am I not seeing these guys
it's because I am currently in a hotel
room in Las Vegas because I'm doing the
pregame show for the match Sims is in
his kitchen you may hear his dogs
parking and we're doing this because
we're grinders and we can't let you guys
down and you need to know what we're
doing and we love you isn't that right
Sims that's right man you're sitting on
that couch he's sitting on a couch in
the MGM Grand I am it's a pretty nice
couch I'm gonna be honest with you man
imagine how many naked butts and people
have done gross things on that thing on
that couch you're sitting on right now I
did think about that and then I thought
am i grosser than them a day might be
well that might be true especially if
your big hairy butts on there now as
well know I'm wearing shorts but no I'm
here for Phil and Tiger and it was a
blast I got him to face up yesterday
Sims and it was good yeah what was the
what was the other than the face up what
was the highlight you get any good
laughs out of any of them did you make
them laugh I'm not like I don't want to
I did the I did the how much is rent in
your head phil mickelson since Tiger
Woods has been living there for two
decades and he said there's a lot of
space but I'll do the thing is when you
make eye contact with Tiger Woods and
you're like four feet away and you
realize it's Tiger frickin woods it I
took a moment and I don't get to do this
a lot where I kind of just took it all
in and I was like what the hell am I
doing here
like Tiger just looked at me and nodded
and I was like holy crap tag here knows
I exist so it was awesome and dude the
courses unbelievable like you're just
driving around Las Vegas and it's a
desert and then all of a sudden you're
in like North Carolina it's gorgeous
after seeing them face to face what I
really want to know is who would win in
an actual fight
forget garlic
not a question who will they meet if
they're fighting my take would be Tiger
is a much more athlete is much more
athletic looking than Phil but I also
know that the reason that I'm going to
eventually do the surprise underdog and
pick fill in this is I think that Phil
is super crafty and he's just gonna
attack Tigers back because I could tell
you Tiger is so protective right now of
his body he's not doing anything crazy
the only athletic thing I feel like he
does anymore is swing a golf club
so I feel like Tiger be worried about
his back giving Phil the advantage yeah
that's where my mind went too right
tiger Tigers got back problems Phil's a
scrapper he's gonna go right after that
weakness a hundred percent Phil's
gouging eyes Tiger is gonna be like this
isn't worth it for my career 100 percent
before we get into all the bets and
recapping everything I don't even want
to start gambling until we talk about
Monday Night Football I was able to
start watching the game on the plane
about you know halfway into the first
quarter I lost it for a little bit but I
was going nuts on this plane I don't
know who the dude next to me was but he
took his shoes off and his socks off and
halfway through the flight through a fat
dip in and he goes to go to the bathroom
like the third quarter and when he's
leaving he goes by the way man I've been
watching your computer screen for the
whole time
hope that's okay this game is amazing
and it was incredible it was such a
wonderful offensive display and I know
Sims that you really got to pour over it
and I just like to hear your take on the
game because I thought it was great and
anyone saying that Pat mahomes lost the
MVP race because he turned it over dude
I don't even know what the hell you're
talking about
like it's just crazy me but I'd really
like to hear Sims your take on the game
well I mean first of all let's just
start there five turnovers by Patrick
Mahone's okay it's not his fault that
you know his coach left career journey
man cam Erving one on one with the best
defensive player in football and he got
blindsided twice so that
I don't understand you no blame in and
of course the the placing a blame and
then giving somebody all the credit all
the time at the quarterback position it
seems all over the place to the media
right now I can't I don't listen to
anything they say he threw an
interception where he got hit as he was
throwing it I'm not gonna blame him
totally for that he's doing interception
at a desperation with 20 seconds to go
in the game because they had to make
something happen if they wanted a chance
to win the football game and they threw
one bad pick six to Sam mu mu I can
never say his name mu Kim and either way
I I don't look at him as being out of
the MVP race by any stretch he also
threw for 460 yards or something like
that and six touchdowns yeah it was an
exciting game it really was there was
tons of offensive weapons on both sides
of the ball I don't like this style of
football game there's no pressure in a
game like this I mean it's there's no
pressure on anybody on the field there's
no pressure on any of the coaches to
manage situations just it's like oh they
scored well here's a play that they
can't defend we'll run it we'll go down
and score now your turn okay I mean
that's that to me is where football is
not fun that's where I get you know this
I think is one of the rare matchups that
could truly be like this in football
because of the all the offensive
weaponry in the game but you know I
don't know everybody seems to think oh
scoring is good and all we're setting a
record pace of points in the season
touchdown passage passing yards are all
through the roof and then forth and then
the games are closed in the fourth
quarter well see to me what's going on
more than anything is we're watering
down football because every game is
gonna be closed because the offense is
never out of a game this day and age and
I'm not specifically just talking to
this game but it we're dancing the fine
line of where the better teams are not
going to be able to win when they should
because the rules are so setup for the
offense and no matter what you're behind
in the fourth quarter or whenever that
may be
hey quarterback makes a dumb decision
throws in the triple coverage
all pass interference first down
quarterback throws it down in the middle
dumb decision receiver gets his head
torn off because quarterback threw a
stupid throw in a stupid decision 15
yards defenseless receiver quarterback
pocket collapses he somehow gets the
ball out of his hands he gets hit in the
head by a right pinky finger first down
15 yards that allowed it so offenses are
never gonna be out of the game because
they set up for the rules right now
that's what's annoying to me about the
future of football I still think the
really good offenses get it and know
that you have to run the ball and be
physical and do all that to things
jumped out to me about the game the fact
that you know what would Bill Belichick
do I know he wouldn't leave Cameron
one-on-one with Aaron Donald all game
long serious ly too much and my other
big takeaway from the game would just be
you know everybody's gonna be able to
get in the shootout with the Kansas City
chief now it's worry about the Chiefs
they have the worst secondary out of any
of the good teams in football they are
at a mismatch almost at every position
that has to cover somebody all they did
was attack Orlando Scandrick just
yesterday good I know they found the
one-on-one matchup with him I'll say
this though the one thing about the
Chiefs defense the thing that really
stuck out to me you were talking about
the big thing in the NFL is get a few
guys on the defensive line and drop a
bunch of people and up into coverage the
the trio of Chris Jones just in Houston
and D Ford like when they don't have to
play an offense that it says
high-powered as the Rams those three
takeover games like that is special it
is I mean they're really good players
but that they're you know I don't know
I'd probably take the big three on the
the RAM over there big 3 what scares me
about the Chiefs is this is their SOSUS
they're just not made for playoff
football I mean they can lose this type
of game to the to the Patriots the steel
or Chargers the Texans everybody in the
first round they could lose this way
they could get bludgeoned by the
Baltimore Ravens and the Ravens to play
good defense and they can run the ball
down their throat that's where I worry
about Kansas City your dial so you're
telling me that we could see the chiefs
chief in the playoffs would you
yeah definitely I mean it's just you
know to me the way they play is it's
dangerous they rely on their quarterback
to stretch the field make big plays that
way it's not in their DNA to be a power
run football team which they probably
have the capability of doing but it's
just not what they are my ability that's
my question is if the Rams somehow get
home-field advantage over the Saints
could you see or even if they don't did
the Rams show you that they could be a
Super Bowl team
yeah the Rams are already a Super Bowl
team firm because of the coaching on
both sides with the fact that Hakeem to
leave will be back and you know their
front seven has the ability I mean again
it's one thing to say oh okay Kansas
City's front seven can do that too well
that was like the only game all year
we've seen Kansas City's front seven do
that like we see the Rams do this every
week so this is not like a one-time
thing when they need big plays there's
somebody on their front seven has really
come through in every game this year
except for the Saints game and that's
where I don't go oh this is not an
outlier this is something that's really
pretty much the norm for what the Rams
can do on defense alright so it was an
amazing game I had a lot of fun watching
it let me recap what happened in week 11
in terms of our picks Sims is still on a
freaking roll guys nine and four against
the spread last week left go seven and
six so your boys batting 500 Sims is
still up there pretty much go in 667 but
Sims finished
- 480 because he lost 750 on Houston
which was just a kick in the old junk
let's go finished - a hundred the Chiefs
covering because they were three and a
half point dogs I did say I love that
half point
I finished down 100 meaning Sims his
bank account is currently at plus 160 on
the year he's over 500 left go his
bank account is plus 160 we are all tied
up going into week 12 Sims the drama is
building what would you say my record
was your overall record right now is 81
75 and for and my overall record is 76
80 and for but as we always say Sims
what matters the most
Aulani is the only thing that matters I
got I didn't even know I had that good
of a week picking the games last week
that was good to hear you really nailed
it you just put all of that money on the
freaking Texans which I would say 90% of
that game I felt like you were gonna
cover and I was gonna cover too but
obviously your cover mattered a lot more
and KY Fairburn missed extra point
missed field goal damn yeah there was a
few there was a few chances for the
Texans to take control of that one but
it's alright that's part of gamblin
let's keep it going let's go let's start
this up alright so I just want to do two
overall Thanksgiving things because
there's three games on Thanksgiving I've
already entered in my left coal ox
before I went to Vegas and it's picking
the three games so I already have these
in just want to say that over the past
two seasons the favored team has
dominated on Thanksgiving six and Oh
straight up five and one against the
spread so just remember that if you're
betting for Thanksgiving and we're gonna
start off with Sims Chicago at Detroit
that that early game and it is Chicago
favored by three in Detroit carry on
Johnson and Marvin Jones might miss the
game and we don't know if Travis Keys
gonna play what do you think Sims yeah
there's a lot of uncertainty about the
game I think the thing I look at with
just as far as the Lions offense versus
the Bears defense the first thing that
bothers me is the fact that carry on
Johnson's not there he is the best
player on the Bears offense I mean the
Lions offense excuse me so them not oh
there's some crowd noise odo but then
not having
it is a big deal for me now you know the
the other side of that matchup with the
Bears offense verse the Lions defense
hey the one thing I'll say since the
Lions got snacks their run defense has
been a lot better I do think the fact
that you know these teams played each
other what 11 days ago and the Lions got
exposed and some of their past coverage
schemes I think that kind of favors the
Lions because I think they're gonna be
the team that's gonna change things up
and know that they can't have the same
plan of attack where the Bears are gonna
go in the matchup going oh well we
should be able to do kind of what works
and last matchup and maybe we'll have a
wrinkle or two here either way listen
Detroit usually Detroit in the Matt
Stafford era I feel like is dangerous on
this game the Lions have Thanksgiving
pride I do I'm gonna go a hundred
dollars on the Bears for this matchup
but I don't sit here and I'm picking the
Bears to win the game 23 to 20 but I
really think this will be a close
football game when all said and done
hold I got y'all up my dog Toto shut it
until you hold on a second I mean hold
on here we go this is what we call grade
any podcast content how often do you get
to go into the home of a media mogul
like Chris Simms and hear him discipline
a little Terrier I'm just gonna start
breaking down my game I don't know I
think Simms needs to hear about it
I do believe that them losing carry on
Johnson is enormous don't mind that
phone call it's not me Marvin Jones
might miss this game too and remember
they traded Golden Tate so right now the
Detroit Lions offense is Kenny gala day
which in itself might be good but I'm
telling you that if it's Theo Riddick
LeGarrette Blount and Kenny Gala day
versus Vic Fangio in a short week I'm
feeling really good about the Bears
defense
hello Sims I was amazing so the main
thing that I was saying Sims is that Vic
Fangio on a short week against an
offense that may be missing Marvin Jones
and kerri-anne Johnson I love Kenny gala
day but I
have to think that that Vic Fangio is
gonna have this bears defense ready to
roll I do agree with you that I'm a
little bit worried about the simplicity
of what I think the Bears are gonna
bring out against the Lions on a short
week but even if true Biscay misses the
game I can make an argument that chase
Daniel can run this offense just as well
as Mitch if not better he's not gonna be
as dangerous running the ball Wow how
about this we got breaking news chase
Daniel is slated to start on Thursday
Ian Rapoport reporting that just
happened so what I still feel confident
in Chase Daniel yeah he'll be able to
execute the offense yes the only thing
you have to worry about with a chase
Daniel is the fact that he just hasn't
played rhythm timing just feel within
the pocket those are the things that are
missing but you mean you made the point
left go I have a hard time the Lions
without their running back you know
without Ben Jones and you know gala day
is really good but he's you know he's
not a superstar I mean he's he's a he's
a receiver that catches really he does a
great job on 5050 balls and when there's
traffic and Stafford gives him a chance
to get it he snags it I have the Bears
winning this game 26 to 21 and I've put
$50 on Chicago the only thing that
scares me the most about this game is
that the Bears played Sunday night and
now they're on Thursday which has to be
the shortest turnaround in the history
of the NFL
yeah that's that's pretty scary that is
that's a brutal turnaround for a team to
do that to them it really is that's not
it's not fair NFL NFL please continue to
put your players at risk it's it's
really it's really nice how you guys do
this flex them to Sunday night and then
do that unbelievable all right so you
got a hundred on the Bears I have 50 on
the Bears yeah now let's go to the
afternoon slate Washington at Dallas
Dallas is favored by seven and a half
and of course Colt McCoy will be
starting this game Sims take it off
hokum yeah well I think okay so just
like you said with chase Daniels I think
that Hall is true for the Redskins and
I'm gonna go sit here and defend this
that I I think
Redskins offense is gonna be every bit
as good if not better with Colt McCoy
your quarterback I mean he is going to
be more willing and to take chances down
the field and be more aggressive and
he's gonna give the coaching staff the
ability to be more aggressive with their
play calling because they know he'll
pull the trigger when something's there
so I don't think the Redskins offense
will miss a beat they have their hands
full regardless against the Cowboys
defense that's amazing do we do we know
what the status is the trent williams
yet I haven't heard anything there I was
literally pulling it up so you keep
going ok but but either way I look at
that as going to be a struggle but I
don't look at the Redskins as Brent
Williams was limited in practice Monday
and Tuesday which means he's practicing
but he's listed as questionable with a
thumb yeah well and that will be big I
mean they need him for this kind of game
but they're not gonna be like totally
overmatched if he's not there I think
when I flip around to the other side and
just go Cowboys offense versus
Washington his defense listen I think
Washington's defense matches up very
well with the Cowboys as we saw in the
first the first time around and I'm not
gonna sit here and go all the Cowboys
offenses the offensive woes have been
fixed and cured because they moved the
ball you know on the Atlanta Falcons
last week which I mean they had six
points through three quarters and you
know really move the ball at the end of
the game or just really on three
different drives against your
Philadelphia Eagles the week before and
I would argue and even in that matchup
your Eagles offense and ability to stay
on the field really wore down your
defense at the end of the day to open up
some of those big lanes at Ezekiel it
has I I think the Redskins are gonna
keep this close I really do like I said
I think their old line with or without
trent williams will not be run over by
this defensive line with the dallas
cowboys III like they're running scheme
i think they have enough offense to get
open against the Cowboys just to move
the ball here and there
and I look at the Redskins defense as
being able to hold the Cowboys offense
at bay for the most part we know the
Redskins like to play a lot of zone
defense we got that and the Cowboys do
not have the type of offense that
pick apart his own defenses so because
of that this is my big man of the week
I'm going 305 on the watch at Washington
Redskins yes I am I am I will tell you
that I am a little chicken here as I'm
saying it but I think the Cowboys will
win the game I'm gonna pick them to win
22:17 but I just have a hard time
sitting here and thinking the Cowboys
can pull away and beat the Redskins by
more than seven and a half points
alright so the first time these team
played Zeke had 15 carries for 33 yards
now granted Amari Cooper wasn't there
that was also the game that we launched
into Dax like everybody was like Dax ox
Jason Garrett's awful the missed field
goal at the end that could have sent it
to overtime dak with the really
unfortunate fumble that led to a
defensive touchdown for Washington dude
and I'll say this to you too the trends
speak to what you're saying since 2011
the Cowboys are Owen seven against the
spread on Thanksgiving and Washington
has played for Thanksgiving games since
2012 and they're three-and-oh against
the spread I a little bit what's up I
said that makes me feel good a little
bit this will also make you feel good
this was one of the five games that I
bolded as the games I feel really
confident I've already submitted this as
a left go lock I actually have the
Cowboys winning this 23 to 20 so six
more points than you and I'm putting 150
on Washington the only thing I'm worried
about is the Washington offensive line
puts Colt in a dangerous spot and
DeMarcus Lawrence is feasted on that
Turkey and Zeke is able to bust one or
two runs out I really wanted to pick
Washington to win this game outright and
I really think they can yes I really
think Washington can win this game but
seven and a half to me is Vegas going
hey two in a row for Dallas right
everyone's gonna freak out about Alex
Smith being injured I I just I couldn't
believe the spread was that big
especially with a half-point over seven
so I'm really confident in this game too
and I have left go locked it so which
means you should probably put on
but I like Washington here to cover that
spread yeah I'm with you man yeah I
think Washington's toughness as a
football team gets a little undervalued
at times and I feel I feel the same
thing about Washington as I feel about
Arizona where I'm like people are not
valuing how good these defenses are that
they take away the best option of the
other team every week and it's just
gonna come down to can those offenses
score points yeah so we're gonna find
out yep we're gonna find out all right
now the game of the day it is going to
be an absolute shootout game of the day
I think that I think that this is the
Manistee game of the day the fantasy
game of the day the exciting game of the
day I think it's the matchup in which
the teams hate each other the most even
though they're all rivalry games Atlanta
New Orleans is an amazing amazing
rivalry which makes me go wow it's a
really big spread New Orleans favored by
13 and I feel like this is gonna be the
first game that we differ so where are
you going with Atlanta and New Orleans
okay again hey just the Saints offense
they're on another level
they're on a new level they're on a new
level I mean they're unstoppable okay I
don't know what other way to say it yes
it worries me about the matchup with the
Falcons yes the Falcons are healthier
you know I know they had some good
moments last week but this is a
different animal as far as the Saints
their run game I mean I think we both
agree is if it's not the best in
football it's certainly in the top two
or three the screens the past the
play-action passes the drop back pass
game I just think it's too much for the
Falcons defense to handle at the end of
the day and the Falcons run defense
already is an issue let alone some of
the injuries they got in the back end as
is and then I flip it over to the other
side and go hey the Falcons offense yes
if they want to win this game they're
gonna have to do it they're gonna have
to win a shootout type of game against
the New Orleans Saints I don't think I
think the Saints can make the Falcons a
little bit one-dimensional as far as
having to throw more than they would
like because the Saints D line is that
stout and good this
have found the right formula on the
defensive side of the ball left go I
mean they just they finally figured out
what formations and personnel sets they
want to play zone on when to play
man-to-man and the right and the right
situations I think that's where I give
them a lot of credit but at the end of
the day I'm putting a hundred dollars on
the Falcons okay I just thought 13
points was a little too much for a team
that is desperate and really if they
lose this game it's over I mean if it's
gonna take about seven miracles for them
to get back into the playoff
conversation if they lose I think the
Saints win the game 31 to 21 but 13
points is just too much for me so one
little tidbit is that since 2014 the
primetime game has hit the under every
year and the over-under for this game is
59 and a half so I understand that
Atlanta is fighting for their lives I
would also say that Sean Payton is
taking lives yeah he is the coach that
you want to bet on right now because he
does not care about saving his teams
he's trying to put the opponents as far
into the dirt as possible which is what
you need when you're facing a team with
a 13-point spread also both teams
offenses are really good on third down
but on defenses is the difference New
Orleans on third down 15th middle of the
pack
Atlanta's third down defense 31st I see
this game what was your score for this
game by the way
3121 Saints that's really interesting
I have Saints 34 to 20 which is a cover
and I see this game coming down to the
end I am putting what I'm putting just
$50 on New Orleans I feel I like New
Orleans but it's a lot of points and I
don't need that fluky touchdown at the
end but I I just see this game as New
Orleans really pounding at home and I
see New Orleans going drive after drive
after Drive and I see Atlanta stalling
out every now and then so I'm only doing
50 just because the
Dean does scare me yeah I hear and I
think your point about like what Sean
Payton is very real man I think it's one
of the most impressive things we've seen
from the Saints this year is they've
never you know even after all these big
wins they've had we've looked at it and
go okay I mean alright they beat
Baltimore in Baltimore well they fall
asleep this week after the game nope
that's all right they beat Minnesota on
Sunday night well they kind of come out
sleepwalking against the Rams nope babe
so they've constantly answered the
challenges even after big wins and I
think that does speak to Sean Payton and
his ability to keep his team motivated
and focused on the task at hand I'm just
gonna wrap this up but I'm gonna go on
to Sunday but my big concern and the
reason before the year that now the
Falcons have had a lot of injuries the
reason that I was picking the Saints to
go to second the division was their
murderers row of opponents in the middle
of the year with Baltimore Minnesota the
Rams all these teams and then for them
to handle what they've done is the
reason right now that I have Sean Payton
Asst coach of the year because it's
pretty damn special alright let's go to
Sunday first game on the slate is going
to be Cleveland at Cincinnati Cincinnati
is favored by three Sims start us off
okay I mean the Browns coming off the
bye week with their new formula on the
offensive side of the ball under Freddie
kitchens I've liked it so far the Browns
have become a run first football team so
uh and that's very beneficial to playing
the Bengals who can't stop anything in
the run game let alone the Browns
ability and Baker Mayfield ability to
strike with downfield throws that's
become more common with Freddie critten
kitchens calling plays now I also worry
about the Browns defense and how it
matches up against the Bengals offense
the Bengals offense is still capable of
ripping off big plays in the pass game
and the run game but I think at the end
of the day what really scares me more
than anything is the Bengals defense and
especially up front is what bothers me
the Browns offensive line is the
strength of their football team and Nick
Chubut running back is special and then
you have to put extra assets into
stopping that run game and I think Baker
may feel
is on his way to being special with some
of the plays I've seen over the last few
weeks
I'm putting $50 on the Browns I'm not
gonna bet a lot of money on two teams
that are very questionable and seemed to
mess up a whole lot
I'm putting 50 on the Browns and I'm
actually gonna pick the Browns to win
their first road game in a long time I'm
gonna go 28 24 Browns get the victory in
Cincinnati against Hugh Jackson I was
gonna say I'm betting on the team that
doesn't have Hugh Jackson
so so what you were saying about the run
Bengals are the worst team in the NFL in
rushing yards per game in defense which
against the Browns who are 5th in
rushing yards per game is not a great
matchup and the Bengals can't run the
ball and the Browns can't stop the run
so the one thing that the Browns defense
is really bad against the Bengals cannot
take advantage of and also the Bengals
are the worst defense in the NFL at
getting off the field on third down AJ
Green might be able to play in this game
but Sims guess what I have the Browns
winning this game too the Browns winning
32 24 ORS but I am also only putting $52
on Cleveland because I could see Joe
Mixon busted run I could see if AJ green
plays maybe yeah throw over the top but
I have to think that Greg Williams is in
that that in that locker room go and
they hired Hugh Jackson let's kill these
guys I agree I think this is the Browns
first win of the year on the road and I
think coming off the bye is a really big
one so I'm putting 50 on the Browns cool
all right somebody wants to say idea hi
oh my god Charlotte the baller shower
Pollard's here say hi to Adam hi Adam
see and you're getting family on the
gambling show there's nothing more
familial than gambling I think that's a
word I didn't like me I'm not sure all
right let's move on sorry Charlotte
we've got business to attend to
let's go come we're okay good Familia is
josh has confirmed that good word - all
right let's move on to another game that
we love San Francisco
coming off the by taking on Tampa Bay in
Tampa with Jameis Winston starting after
he came back in the second half after
Ryan Fitzpatrick was throwing up 50/50
lob balls and it's gonna be Jameis at
home with favored by three and a half
against the Niners Sims take it away
well of course the first thing I think
about with this matchup and anytime
really anybody plays the 49ers in a Kyle
Shannon offense is I go can they stop
the run can they do that because that's
the first thing you have to do when you
buy the 49ers and I don't feel
necessarily comfortable that the
Buccaneers can stop the run consistently
so I look at that and go okay and what
usually that does off of that is we've
seen how Shanahan and the 49ers once
they can run the ball a little bit it
just opens up their pass game - to the
point where it almost becomes
defenseless with all the play actions
and boots and things like that now I do
worry about the 49ers defense against
the Bucs and the way the 49ers play they
are an aggressive defense they play a
lot of single safety coverages they're
gonna give Mike I mean Evans and DeSean
Jackson opportunities to make a few
plays there's no doubt about that but I
think more than anything I'm just gonna
go with the fact that the 49ers can run
the ball they have a better defense
they've had the week off and here we are
the Buccaneers making their third
quarterback change of the year I have no
faith in their defense because of that
I'm going $100 on the 49ers I think the
49ers are going to win the game outright
I'm picking them to win 28 to 27 I
thought about going 50 here because it
kind of goes to the game we just talked
about with the Browns and bagel Bengals
I don't like putting $100 on teams that
are very iffy in situational football
but I think that the 49ers at least will
keep this within three and a half if not
win the game I love it I'm gonna say
this right now that I'm picking the San
Francisco 49ers to win outright
as well so this is very very interesting
that they both have two upsets winning
OJ Howard goes on IR as you mentioned
Niners coming off of a bye and Kyle
Shanahan gets an extra week to take on
one of the worst foot but worst defenses
in football like sign me up
the reason this game scares me and the
reason that I am only gonna be putting
fifty dollars on this game Simms is
because these are the two worst teams in
the NFL in turnover margin Tampa Bay is
minus 23 San Francisco is minus 15 so I
don't know what's gonna happen in this
game because neither of the teams
protect the ball the Bucs are 19th in
the NFL in defending the run which goes
to what you were saying but I'm gonna
tell you what men say if it just goes
the worst red zone defense in the NFL
Tampa Bay is gonna put up points and the
other thing that scares me for the
Niners is they're doing the one o'clock
Eastern game yes right since 2015 this
is straight-up the Niners are oh and 11
having to play at one o'clock on the
East Coast but with all of that said I
just trust Kyle and I trust Mullins
protecting the ball because I don't
really think either of those
interceptions were his fault last game
against the Giants and I do think the
running game is gonna make it very hard
for the Bucs
to get their offense on the field a lot
I'm going Niners 31:28 and I am putting
$50 on the Niners I feel pretty good
about it yeah I'm with you I feel good
about it - it's always hard bettin on
teams that like you said or if they turn
the ball over too much but my thoughts
were and we're very similar to yours
alright so Niners knock enough so we
have to upset wins right they're back to
back next game is going to be
Jacksonville at Buffalo oh and by the
way just to be as Josh just chimed in
it's gonna be 81 in Sonny and Tampa with
70% humidity perfect playing conditions
perfect playing conditions
okay so Jags bills we get the line is
Jaguars by three jaguars by three it's
in Buffalo what's the weather gonna be
like there's Josh want to text you that
before this is over I am interested to
hear that
at the end of the day but I'll get it
actually checked it earlier it's like a
42 degree day Saturday supposed to rain
Monday it's supposed to rain but I
didn't see any cuz I did check this cuz
I was like if there's any snow in the
air I'm I'm really liking this but what
do you think well I mean this is gonna
be a defensive struggle I think this
would be a lot like what we saw in the
wild card playoff game last year between
Jacksonville and Buffalo except it's
gonna be worse quarterback play than
that playoff game and there's less
offensive weapons especially for Buffalo
on that side of the ball as compared to
last year
I can't imagine either team scoring a
whole lot of points in this matchup I
think this is gonna be a run the
football in between the tackles try to
manage the game as a head coach and keep
it's gonna be a fight for field position
that's really what I see at the end of
the day I you know Josh Allen his status
for the game him coming back having to
deal with this defense right off the bat
I think would be the number one thing
that scares me
of course I think both defenses are
phenomenal I'm going with the team
really that I just think is more
talented and that's still the
Jacksonville Jaguars
I'm gonna put $100 on the Jags I know
they're favored by three I do think this
is a fuel gold ish type game I picked
the Jags to win fifteen to ten I
envision them scoring a touchdown and
then kicking three field goals something
along those lines and I figure the bills
score one touchdown and maybe kick a
field well something like that so that's
why I go the Jags the Jags defense was
phenomenal last week in the game against
Pittsburgh it's not easy when you have
to be on the field every fourth play
against the Pittsburgh Steelers left go
Jalen Ramsey was amazing in that
football game just so yeah yeah what
tell me a little bit about the film that
you saw the Jacksonville yeah I mean
Jacksonville got back to a little bit of
what they did last year on the offensive
side of the ball which was just mash
people just well there's no scheme it's
literally just like five guys go
straight forward and like it's like 300
when they have like the shield's in
front of them and they're just like work
forward and then we got this scary
[ __ ] Leonard Bart fournette behind
and he's just gonna mash you even more
that's kind of what they did but of
course Pittsburgh got a feel for that
Blake bortles was shaky so that started
to shut down and the Jags managed Blake
bortles which is what they had to do cuz
he was having one of those days and then
on the other side of the ball the Jags
defense was amazing I mean it really was
I will say this and the man to man up
between Ramsey and Antonio Brown there's
no question who won that matchup Jalen
Ramsey won it straight up there's really
really only one play all game where
Antonio Brown flat-out beat Jalen Ramsey
and it was a double move and the ball
ended up not going his way I know
everyone's gonna look at the 78-yard
touchdown pass and Antonio Brown had
that was quarters coverage that was the
safeties fault who screwed that play up
I know Jalen Ramsey looks like he's
chasing Antonio Brown but that was not
his responsibility there Jalen Ramsey
was really phenomenal the Jaguars got to
be sick after that that's what I saw on
the film but like I said I'm going a
hundred on the Jags let's go I am
thinking that the Jaguars had one of
their three performances that Phil Simms
said last week when I look at the
Jaguars what how they came out against
Pittsburgh that was an emotional
performance and I think that we're gonna
see a letdown from the Jaguars this week
I always talk about teams having to go
to Buffalo not playing to their full
potential I also look at Buffalo top ten
on defense against the pass and against
the run and they're coming off a bye and
I think when I look at Buffalo I will
say this Brian day ball he's not working
with a lot but I know that in a game
when he's got a little bit of time he
can be a little creative like he did
against the Patriots and Shawn McDermott
with a lot of time to figure out an
offense that he figured out last year oh
man I like I think the Jaguar is in a
really really tough spot I also go men I
mean it's I don't I don't I have the
game as 16 to 13 and I'm picking Buffalo
to win this game out right I'm putting
$50
here on Buffalo and I really think that
I'm hoping that Buffalo uses Josh Allen
the way that we want Jacksonville to use
Blake bortles right let's do I know that
you don't want to take your top you know
10 pick and run them a lot against a
really scary defense but you know well
time to run smart runs getting them on
the outside I know that Jacksonville is
more talented but I just I just think
that Buffalo right now is the better
coached team and I know that's kind of
crazy to say but I'm going Buffalo 1630
and putting $15 on it okay 5050 excuse
me
50 all right let's move on to Oakland at
Baltimore Oakland gets an emotional win
in the final five seconds where Jon
Gruden Airy and and Derek are yelling at
each other and they make it work off a
nice throw to Seth Roberts Baltimore a
changing of their identity it looks like
Joe Flacco is gonna be out again the
Lamar Jackson experience continues and
this game is in Baltimore Baltimore is
favored by ten and a half Sims what are
you thinking well I mean I think the
first thing we talked about is that
Ravens offense what I saw in film last
week from Lamar Jackson I was rather
impressed with what I saw now they kept
it kind of simple in the pass game for
Lamar Jackson and it wasn't perfect I
mean he had probably too shaky decisions
the one he threw an interception on
there was another play in the first half
where he kind of scrambled to his left
and threw a ball that should have been
intercepted by Sean Williams and he
dropped it but other than that played
the game pretty damn clean and the thing
I like about Lamar Jackson he was very
comfortable in the pocket man the ball
came out of his hand clean on every
single throw throughout the day he is
really great at finding lanes to throw
it as a drop-back passer I mean I I know
I we've talked about this before his
ability to kind of drop his arm throw
sidearm
change his throwing angles according to
where defensive linemen are it's really
impressive he is a natural thrower of
the football I really watch them on film
let go and
this style of play fits the Baltimore
Ravens better than when Joe Flacco's in
there at quarterback you know I know
you're high on Gus Edwards Gus Edwards
is the best running back on the
Baltimore Ravens and the combination of
him and Lamar I think it's a lot more
dangerous than Lamar and Alex Collins
why you say that because when you have
to defend Lamar you're really worried
about defending the perimeter of the
defense right so that strings out
linebackers and even defensive linemen
to always go oh wait wait this is Lamar
have it around the edge let me pause for
a second then all sudden damn its Gus
said we're running right by us up the
middle so it's a good combination of
power and speed between both of them
that would be my little breakdown of
their offense but either way I look at
that and go man Baltimore that o-line
the Raiders having to travel across the
country playing a game against a big
physical team like the Ravens
I think the Ravens are gonna have their
way in the run game and of course
there's no matchup for a little more
Jackson to be scared of in the secondary
with the Oakland Raiders either and then
I flip it around and I just don't see
how Oakland consistently moves the ball
on the Baltimore Ravens defense the
Baltimore Ravens defense is still cream
of the crop one of the best defenses in
the sport again they struggled against
some good teams and really because their
offense put them in some bad situations
over the last few weeks that's why they
lost some of those games but I think
they're on the right track I think this
style play like I said with them running
the ball controlling the clock is only
going to help them I'm going with the
Baltimore Ravens to win this game but
I'm putting $50 on the Raiders okay Wow
I know I know well because I don't see
the Ravens blowing anybody out with a
style play you know me I just picked my
scores and then I looked at the spreads
after I have the Ravens winning 20 to 10
so - this is so funny I'm off on the 0.5
and that's why I went 50 on the Raiders
alright so I think that for the longest
time the Ravens were sitting there and
they go we have Joe Flacco we got to
find a way to get this passing game
going we've invested and Willie Snead
and Michael Crabtree and John Brown we
got all these weapons and really what
they are is a defense that's gonna
you down and a team that's gonna pound
you the Raiders are the 31st defense
against rushing yards per game Ravens
defense number 2 versus the pass
number 3 versus the run the Raiders
should not be doing anything especially
with so many of their wide receivers
being hurt and really just related
relying on Jared Cook I do believe that
the Ravens in one week found their new I
offense offensive identity shout-out to
Gus Edwards and shout out to Rutgers
Josh's Rutgers for producing this guy I
think that all along they wanted to bash
people and Alex Collins looks like a
physical runner but he just doesn't
physically run like he he looks like
he's breaking tackles but he's not going
anywhere
movement his hair's moving his legs are
moving real fast but they're not
actually going anywhere and I think that
and Gus is just going straight line and
he's faster straight ahead in this 40
time and all that so I think that the
Ravens are gonna be able to stretch this
Raiders team out and then pound them
with Gus Edwards I also think that we're
gonna see some Oakland turnovers and I
do think that them having that win and
then flying across the country at one
o'clock I also think it's gonna be 20 to
10 but then I think the Ravens are gonna
score another one and they're gonna win
this game 27 to 10 and I am putting a
hundred and fifty dollars on the Ravens
to win this game and cover the spread
ten and a half I think that the Ravens
are about to go on a nice little tear
against a lot of weak defenses in the
NFL and I think that all of a sudden
you're gonna start seeing the the Ravens
making a nice run for that succeed I
mean when you look at this team let me
pull up the opponents that they're play
in the next few weeks because I'm
fascinated by the run that I think
they're gonna make when you look at who
the Ravens are facing they go home
against Oakland no defense ad Atlanta no
defense at Kansas City no defense home
against Tampa Bay no defense and I think
that their defense is gonna figure out a
lot now they do have to take on Atlanta
in Kansas City but I
see the Ravens making a nice little run
here as Lamar and Gus get settled in and
hopefully they employ a lot of the
play-action pass yep yeah I mean I'm
with you man I certainly could see that
too this the schedule sets up for them
to play Raven football and win games
they the way they like to win them
should be interesting all right Seattle
at Carolina in I would say the
unheralded one of the games of the week
two teams that are gonna be fighting
over a wild-card spot Carolina coming
off back-to-back losses to two weeks ago
Thursday night embarrassing against
Pittsburgh I'd say their loss to Detroit
was embarrassing as well the way they
kind of came out flat and flubbed it at
the end Seattle kind of looking like
they're finding their stride it looks
really good in there Thursday night game
against Green Bay Aaron Rodgers had a
few big passes but the Seattle running
game is looking good Carolina at home
favored by three and a half Sims yeah I
mean extremely you know equal playing
field here these are too similar styles
of football I mean we of course have
mobile quarterbacks we both have teams
who like to run the football you know
their defenses that put pride into
stopping the run first so it's always an
intriguing matchup from that standpoint
I think when I look at like the Seattle
Seahawks defense against the Carolina
Panthers you know I do think Carolina
matches up well with the this type of
style the Seattle plays okay gonna leave
a lot of single high safety certainly
Cam Newton's not afraid to throw the
ball outside the numbers verse
one-on-one coverage especially with some
of these guys he's got at receiver now
can the Carolina Panthers run the ball
consistently on the Seattle Seahawks I
think so I'm not gonna say consistently
but I think enough to help out their
pass game help out their play-action
pass game that was one thing that I
really was kind of annoyed with last
week watching Panthers vs lions on film
I do think the Panthers went through way
too many stretches of getting away from
the run game they became very pass happy
in that game last week and blew some
situations forget the extra
point you know the big play we saw DJ
more have where he caught the ball
unless I minded got caught at the 8 yard
line they came away with no points on
that drive you know dude it was so
pathetic right so there was you know
that was a cheap shot field goal that
was shorter than an extra point that was
missed there you know so I look at that
now the other side of the ball is the
Carolina Panthers who of course have a
very good defense we know that I worry
about Carolina's run defense a little
bit in this matchup now I know like
Carolina has a better run defense in
Seattle but I think Seattle's run attack
is better than Carolina and what they do
would they're pulling guards and all
these running backs they got do we know
what the deal is
Rashad Kenney and we heard that yet left
go I have not but I can check right in
her either way I mean it's a shame cuz
he kind of hurt himself on that first
awesome run he had in that Thursday
great I know and he was never the same
after that he was obviously nursing some
type of injury there I think when I come
down to this game bottom line is it's a
very evenly matched football game the
fact that the Seahawks have to go across
the country and play a one o'clock game
against the Carolina Panthers I think
scares me a little bit we know how well
Carolyn has played at home this year and
because of that I'm gonna pick the
Panthers to win but I'm betting $100 on
the Seahawks I'm gonna take this box to
lose a close one I'm picking the
Panthers 24 21
but $100 on the Seahawks that cover that
three and a half point spread so I do
think that the Russell Wilson offense
seems to be clicking right now to me it
seems to be Doug Baldwin underneath or
outside Tyler Lockett gets three to four
deep shots a game but other than that
it's Chris Carson its Rashad Penny it
screams I know that it's the opposite of
what we saw Monday night but that's
Seattle's personnel and I think that
they're also masking a defense that can
let up big plays by keeping their
defense off the field a lot and I think
I'd like to see her oh so Wilson run
like he does in the last eight minutes
of a game the whole game I just think
that's part of
game Panthers are five and Oh at home
and I checked out how they score at home
versus on the road when the Panthers are
on the road their score in 20 points a
game that's what we saw in Pittsburgh
that's what we saw in Detroit when
they're at home if you take away that
Dallas week one game they're averaging
35 and a half points per game at home
it's a different team at home Cam Newton
is comfortable we're seeing a lot more
of the outside weapons DJ more and then
who's my who's my little jitterbug from
Ohio State
Curtis sample right Curtis Samuel seems
to have more big plays at home I look at
this game and I have the Panthers
winning this game 34 to 31 so a little
bit more high scoring than yours because
I think the Panthers score more at home
and I also when I looked at Seattle on
the road you know they put up 31 in LA
they put up 28 in Detroit they were in
London they put up 27 so I think I think
Carolina's defense is in Carolina's
defense has actually allowed a lot more
points at home member all the points
that they allowed to the Giants at home
Tampa Bay they let up 28 so I think it's
gonna be a little bit more high-scoring
but I'm also betting on Seattle I'm
putting $50.00 on Seattle and it really
comes down to that half point because I
think it's gonna be a field goal
trade-off game but I do think Carolina
gets this one because I find them to be
a little bit more desperate right now
and I also think very different team at
home so I'm going $50 on Seattle there
we get a disagreement yet our big
disagreements thus far you're going
Jacksonville I'm going Buffalo you're
going Atlanta and I'm going New Orleans
and you're also betting on Oakland and
I'm betting on other rave vaults right
right got you so I would say a lot of
our scores have been very close where we
end up putting our money is the big
decision there right right all right but
I think that's gonna be an amazing game
I think that could be the the best game
of the one o'clock that everyone's
talking about moving forward New England
at the Jets the Patriots are favored
by nine and a half Patriots and Jets
coming off of a bye and this game is
gonna be at MetLife yeah at MetLife this
is one of the few games you know for the
rest of the year that the Jets fanbase
will be extremely charged up and ready
to go because they of course hate the
New England Patriots traditionally have
kept these games somewhat close it is a
big rivalry game and of course the Jets
can define their year in a lot of ways
when they beat a team like new and good
you know I look at it like this Todd
Bowles his defense first the New England
Patriots it's given them problems at
times it really has I mean even dating
back to his days at Arizona when he was
there and and coaching that defense and
dealing with New England you know I do
think their style of play the fact that
they have corners on the outside that
can play some man-to-man Bowls can be
creative as far as where he drops people
in zone coverages but the big issue
would that matchup more than anything is
at some point the Jets defense will be
compromised because they can't get
pressure on the quarterback without
rushing five or six and I like that
combination against Tom Brady I mean
either one he's gonna figure out who's
coming and block it up and then have
matchups down the field he likes or two
he's just gonna get the ball out of his
hands when he does feel compromised and
they've tricked them and you're not
gonna get the sack anyways so that's
what I don't like about that matchup and
New England
it sounds like Gronk is gonna be healthy
and ready to play the game
so with that it sounds like you'll have
a Sony Michele that's healthier I don't
know what the deal is with Shaq Mason
but no England can beat you a lot of
different ways I'm not gonna be skewed
by what we saw in Tennessee a few weeks
I think you're gonna see a refocused New
England team and then just real quickly
on the other side of the ball what what
am I supposed to buy into it the New
York Jets offense that's that's what I'd
like to know I mean so there's really
nothing there I like in that matchup for
the Jets I mean they're gonna have to be
cute they're gonna have to have some
trick plays I think ready to kind of
keep themself in this game let go I'm
really excited to see
just in this matchup - if Duke Dawson
gets to play for the Patriots he was
their second round pick out of Florida
they they designated him for return off
IR I thought a lot of him coming out in
the draft the patrons do need another
cover guy so that's just one thing I'm
looking for but getting back to the
point at hand I am putting $100 on the
Patriots I'm picking them to win 27 to
17 I could certainly see it being more
than that but like I said the fact that
it's in New York the Jets fan base will
be ready to go Bowles was embarrassed
before the bye week I guess what scares
me is that they can keep it a little
closer than we may think you are
absolutely right in terms of the Jets
have historically kept this game close
but I don't see this Jets team being
like those other Jets teams the injuries
to the secondary their inability to get
after the quarterback I felt like a lot
of those Jets teams over the years had a
lot of great defensive players and when
I look at this Jets team I see Leonard
Williams and that's really hit Jamal
Jamal Adams is honestly every time I
watch him he reminds me of Brian Dawkins
yeah it's it's really incredible to
watch that dude rush the passer and and
press the line of scrimmage but the Jets
weren't the only team that got
embarrassed before the body yeah that
that was one of the worst losses in the
Patriots Bill Belichick era and and
they're healthy and they have a body and
I think that this is going to be the
second half surge where Sims man I turn
on NFL Network which I don't really
watch I don't really watch a lot of TV
at home and I'm watching these guys pick
in their top five teams and their power
ranking and most of them did not have
the Patriots in their top five and I'm
just telling everybody right now I know
the Chiefs are good I know the Chargers
are good I know the Steelers are good
but I'm telling you the Patriots will be
one of the last four teams playing
because of the Patriots and that's what
happens and to not have them in your top
five is crazy no team was more
embarrassed
other than the Jets going into their bye
week than the Patriots that was one of
the worst losses that Bill Belichick has
ever suffered taking on the Tennessee
Titans I know that the Jets have
historically played the Patriots well
but when I look at the pain
I look at the Jets they usually have a
lot of good defenders and other than
Jamal Adams and Leonard Williams I don't
see that right now I also see a lot of
holes in the Jets defensive schemes I'm
seeing teams pile up points against the
Jets like you said Gronk is gonna be
back the team should be healthy and
they're motivated and I see this team
the Patriots winning 31 to 10 and I am
putting $300 on the Patriots well I just
I do not see an offensive threat from
the Jets that makes me think the
Patriots are not going to cover this
game by more than 10 I do not understand
why the Saints are favored by more
against the Falcons than the Patriots
are against an offensive inept team
right now in the Jets I haven't seen
anything out of McCown if Darnell comes
back I don't think he's gonna be ok so I
I really like this game I really like
the Patriots I know it's a bye week
against the 4-minute like a team they
play a lot but I think the Patriots are
gonna come out fast like really fast I
feel really good about this game yeah oh
good for you
yeah I mean I couldn't go that strong on
it just because I think the Jets defense
is a little better than you're giving it
credit for but but I understand your
thoughts there all the way I just didn't
know what to expect from the Patriots
why couldn't I couldn't bet hard on it
and I'm with you too left go and your
fact about like you know power ranking
the top teams in football I mean the
Patriots would be number 3 on my list I
mean I would go Ram I would go Saints
Rams and then the England Patriots
you know the the the me character city
the way they play is dangerous it really
is and the way they've played lately I
just I don't know what to think of the
Chiefs I mean I really don't I guess
that would make them number 4 but it's
really close between them and Pittsburgh
right now in my eyes awesome I love that
all right Giants at Philadelphia and my
team is falling apart and the Giants
have won two in a row and if the Giants
beat the Eagles they have the same
freaking record that is unbelievable to
say
thank we really do and by the way Sims I
don't know if you know this but the Eli
propaganda is starting back up again he
did so well against Tampa Bay
Eli played well against the Niners
defense and the Bucs defense two of the
worst defenses in the NFL and I'm
looking at the New York media saying see
what happens when Eli has time the
propaganda for Eli Manning to be the
starting quarterback on the Giants next
year is in full force and now he's
taking on a team that has Crowe Vaughn
LeBlanc playing in the secondary and he
might be able to do it again Sims the
Eagles are favored by six at home how do
you think this one goes down god damn it
thank you that might be good luck last
time he said that you guys win won the
Superbowl so man fill up in the house
yeah even a little shout out he was
going right back to Madden so he's back
that's here okay I don't know what I
wanted to say something else there and I
completely lost I was talking about the
Eli propaganda we my propaganda yes I
mean first of all the 49ers defense is
better than you're giving it credit for
it's not a horrible unit in fact I think
there were top-ten defense in the league
right now just so you know but I'm just
saying that when you let's say were
given the field sure the short field
twice you know yeah you play meant 101
coverage with Odell get out of here or
say Quan either way I get that and then
Peyton Manning breaks it down for ESPN
and adds to the propaganda that's what
the this is a little bit it's a
propaganda machine the Manning's and the
Giants and all that certainly is you
know I look at this matchup okay
and I think the big thing for the Giants
offense for your Eagles defense is can
they just protect up front if they can
protect up front they're gonna be able
to move the ball on the Eagles than that
beat up secondary you know the Eagles
are gonna have to be careful on how they
approach covering the New York Giants
because of what you just talked about
some of those one-on-one matchups are
certainly not in the Eagles favor
so stop
the run getting passed protection I mean
getting passed pressure on Eli will be
paramount in this game because if Eli
does have the proper amount of time in
the pocket it's only a matter of time
before receivers get open downfield now
I look at her the other way and the
Giants defense kind of disappointing to
a degree it has not been as dominant all
year long as I would have been expected
it to be you know I definitely look at
this one of these games where I think
Carson Wentz can sit back there by time
and make just enough happen in the past
game I think this would be a very close
game I'm betting $100 on the Giants I
don't feel overly confident because it
is only one play or one mismatch away
from the Giants getting a big play in
the past game or a screen to say qualm
Barkley something like that to where
this game gets very even or close or
interesting but I think at the end of
the day since you guys are at home and
you have the better quarterback and you
still have your defensive line that I'm
gonna give you guys the slight advantage
I think the Eagles win 24 21 but I'm
betting a hundred on the Giants and
you're gonna feel the reason I love it
in a second I look at this game and I go
who has the playmakers the Giants have
the playmakers who has the Eagles have
the injury problems I got Malcolm
Jenkins saying that he's hating this
team's energy right now I've watched the
Eagles for the last three weeks tried to
try and rile everybody up Michael
Bennett was making comments last week
now it's Malcolm Jenkins making comments
I look at this game and I'm just gonna
say it this is the tombstone game this
is here lies the Superbowl champion
Eagles their season ended in week 12
because I see this game 24 to 22 Sims
right and the Giants win whoa I think
that the Eagles reign of terror over the
Giants I think very fittingly they've
they've destroyed this team 17 in the
last
21 I talk about it all the time they've
won like five in a row or something like
that that's not exact I don't know what
that number is but I think that their
season ends as the rain over the Giants
end and I think Eli is going to have
time which is like really annoying to me
because I love killing Eli but I think
that when I watch that you know why what
do you what do you think why you know
that's I mean I hear you yeah well I
will say I will say this I will say this
Timmy Jernigan is supposed to come back
and it could be interesting it's more of
when I watch that first game that game
should not have been that much of a
blowout because they didn't know how to
use say Kwan and I feel like what's
gonna happen is is the misdirections
that the Giants are able to use of the
say Quan screens and getting Odell more
out there I just think that what I meant
was when Eli does have time because
there's no one in the secondary he's
going to take advantage of it where I
felt like last time when he had time you
still had Rodney McCloud you still had
all of the corner Sydney Jones played
one of his best game and none of those
guys are there now so I just think that
the Giants are gonna actually capitalize
on their big plays this time unlike last
time and I mean the Giants have
confidence and I think the Eagles don't
and I think this is a 24 to 22 game and
I - and putting $100 on the Giants are
you shocked by that I mean I am shocked
that you're picking them to win the game
I am I am
yes I'm not shocked by your bet six is a
lot yeah six is a lot your yeah six is
too much for me and III you know listen
you make a lot of good points I hear
your concerns I just think with your D
line their inability to rush the passer
and get sacks that's why in Carson I'll
maybe he'll be able to make you know two
or three plays that get them to win but
it's gonna be close I'm with you there
all the way I'm also going to admit
something there's probably a part of me
that's trying to mush it and let the
opposite happen if I'm gonna be very
honest with everybody okay let's move on
to the next one
Chargers favored by 12 and a half
Hosting Arizona both of these teams
suffered absolutely demoralizing late
losses both teams pretty much had the
game in hand Raiders had a late drive to
upset the Cardinals Chargers I mean
they're up by double digits in the third
quarter the Von Miller interception the
the very very odd Phil Rivers throw into
the dirt on a crucial third down they
lose that game to Denver so they're both
coming out to me this game's an absolute
dogfight Sims because both teams are
gonna be really really angry obviously
the Chargers have more to play for how
do you see this game happenin wale well
I think the you know again I think a lot
of this Arizona defense I think you both
that you and I both have seen that it's
come together quite nicely you know over
the last month I mean Steve Wilkes is a
good defense of mine their sound they
don't beat themselves a whole lot I do
think this is a tough matchup for them
because this is the well-rounded offense
with the Los Angeles chargers you know
this is you know the Cardinals have
gotten the chance to play some teams
here where they've looked better on
defense because there are teams that are
not nearly as balanced maybe as some of
the other teams I know the Raiders ran
the ball okay last week but I don't look
at their offense as being special that
way Kansas City is certainly a task
first type of football team so I still
guess I worry about the Cardinals run
defense against the Chargers is what I
would say and because of that I always
worry about passes off of that that
would be my big question mark as far as
you know Arizona's defense versus the
Chargers offense now if I was gonna flip
it around the other way
you know the Arizona offense I certainly
like it it's improved since Byron
Leftwich has taken over I liked what I
see from Josh Rosen you know their run
game showed some spark last week there's
there's no Corey lujon Joey Bosa he'll
be a week better I guess more than
anything I just don't know if the
Chargers are still talent I mean the
Cardinals are still talented enough to
keep pace with the Chargers you know
again I like what the Cardinals do on
defense but I still think they're gonna
have their hands full across the board
with some of these matchups and this
all game and I think because of that you
know I'm picking the charger to win 27
to 17 but I'm pick putting 50 dollars on
the Cardinals just because 12 and 1/2 is
too much I do think that the Cardinals
will be able to score just enough and
slow down the Chargers Justin Justin out
to where they don't get blown off the
field let me say this to you the
Chargers should be higher in rushing
attempts per game their 17th they only
averaged 25 attempts per game that's oh
that's less than one better than the
Chiefs in terms of attempts per game the
Chiefs are 20th the Chargers are 17th
and therein lies the issue with the
Chargers in my mind Sims is that they
should be doing some leash I feel like
their offense should be going out of
Melvin Gordon and and running out of the
play-action but they're still running
that chargers three wide Phillip Rivers
giddy up offense and as much as I love
Phillip and I really do love him and I
think he's a great quarterback I just
don't like bet on the Chargers and I say
it every week on Denzel Perryman and
Korey liege it out for the season and I
think what I've seen out of the
Cardinals is the Cardinals now know who
they are it's Josh Rosen looking for
David Johnson and Larry Fitzgerald and
it's every week and they're able to
protect Josh Rosen by making it kind of
quick and getting the ball out of his
hands because that offensive line is
very beat up and I think that's two
really good run stoppers for the
Chargers that are gonna be out and I
don't have a lot of faith in that
Chargers defense I think 12 and a half
is a number in which people are going
they're still thinking Arizona sucks
they're still thinking that their bottom
of the barrel but every time I watch
Arizona even if it's on the road like
they were 16 and a half point dogs for
Kansas City and they really had a chance
to win that game but I see the Chargers
win in this game 23 to 21 and I'm
putting $50 on Arizona just because I
could also see that I could also see the
Chargers coming out and being like it's
time to rain terror but 12 and a half is
way too many points when
of no home-field advantage and the
Chargers like I saw a clip from the
Chargers Broncos game where Von Miller
after the game was going nuts and he
turned around and the entire stadium was
orange the entire stadium was Denver
Broncos fan
I don't know how Arizona fans are gonna
travel that well I just think 12 and a
half and the Chargers are just not a
team I like to bet on especially with a
spread that big what did your would you
put on that am I trying 50 so less than
you 50 I won 50 - I won 50 in the cards
I just don't understand you where you
picked your biggest margins of scores
those are the games you don't bet on I
don't understand that sometimes because
because in my mind I mean you guys learn
from winning a game getting six so now
that you got them getting eight but you
didn't bet hard on them I don't
understand that I bet hundred I bet
hundred which I'm doing a lot of 50s so
for me a hundred is actually a good
amount but I am I'm betting more and I'm
gonna have some more big bets coming out
right now but I'm putting a look look
who I bet my money on I bet my money on
New England I bet my money on Baltimore
taking on Oakland and I bet my money on
Washington I'm betting on the consistent
teams where in this game I'm betting
against the team that I that is
inconsistent but I don't find the
Arizona to be I find them to be
consistent in their play but there's a
lot of you know what happens if the
Chargers and Joey Bosa are able to get
to Josh Rosen I have questions I'm just
putting my money on the teams that I
find that I have more faith in so don't
question me okay we're tied yeah all
right
Miami who's cooking Danielle is uh I
don't know what she's doing over here
she's doing something she's getting
ready for the big meal tomorrow oh very
nice yeah I feel like I need to figure
out what I'm gonna do for things giving
dinner tomorrow all right
Miami at Indy Indy is favored by eight
and we are in Indianapolis Miami is
coming off of a bye
Indy very well-documented by us and
everybody else
Andrew Luck has not been sacked in five
games they're coming out of a blowout
win over the Tennessee Titans and
they're favored by eight what are you
thinking here Sims well I mean Nicole by
the way by the way Ryan Kelly the center
is out okay all right
that hurts the Colts the Colts offense
and what it's doing right now is pretty
special I mean it really is I mean the
way they're protecting the way they're
smashing people at the line of scrimmage
in the run game I mean all things I look
at that and go wow
Miami is in deep crap trying to stop
this Colts offense they really are the
one thing they got in their favor of
Miami is at least they got some corners
you can match up man-to-man a little bit
and they can put in an Xavier Tower on
@ey Hilton and feel comfortable about
that some of the time of course you
don't want to live in that world or
you're gonna get burned eventually that
would be the only thing but I really
have a hard time thinking Miami is gonna
slow down the Colts a whole lot on that
side of the ball I I really do you know
whether it's run game or pass game you
know the Dolphins don't have enough big
people in the middle of their defense
the Dolphins can rush the passer a
little bit but again this is a Colts
offensive line that's shown that it's
very capable of pass we're taking
against the best D lines in the sport I
flip it around and you know hey the
Colts are nothing groundbreaking on the
defensive side of the ball I guess this
is where I worry about the matchup a
little bit like I expect the Colts to
win this football game but with extra
time that the Miami Dolphins have had
with Adam GaSe probably reevaluating his
offense a little bit and the Colts
defense not being anything special you
know some young talent certainly they're
good against the run they're not great
they definitely have some issues at
corner on the outside when they have to
play some teams that have a good passing
game and receivers at the end of the day
I don't like this matchup for the Miami
Dolphins I'm betting $100 on the Colts I
wanted to bet more but I think the Colts
defense and the fact that the Dolphins
have had the week off I guess scare me
just a little bit I think the Colts win
the game 28 to 17 but I'm not sitting
here ready to put my stamp of approval
on all the Colts er than one of the most
consistent teams in the sports and I'm
gonna put my money on them I need to see
a few more I guess games or weeks before
I started doing that
I do not Miami is 28th in the NFL and
sacks per pass attempt I'm gonna say
this right now
luck is not getting sacked again this
week there's gonna be six games in a row
because the strength in my mind of the
pass rush of the cut of the Dolphins is
on the outside it's cam wake it's Robert
Quinn and the Colts whenever that
happens Andrew Luck just steps up in the
pocket and I think he's fine
the thing is about the Dolphins too
they've won these crazy games at home
they're 1 in 4 on the road and their
only win on the road was the Jets in
week 2
they've lost in their last four Road
games by a combined 79 points the Colts
in their last three home games have won
by combined 63 points and remember
Jacksonville was struggling most of the
game until they just started dumping it
down every time Miami's magic only
happens at home I think it runs out here
I don't care if it's a week off I know
that you like Adam GaSe and I know that
he's able to draw some things up but his
obsession with playing Frank Gore over
Kenyan Drake has been frustrating me the
entire year because I after the Texans
game I don't understand how he didn't
completely change maybe it starts this
week I have the Colts winning this game
31 to 17 and I am putting $300 on Andrew
Luck and the Colts offense to pound and
pound and you can put save Ian Howard on
T Y Hilton that's fine it's gonna be the
Jack Doyle and Eric Ebron show and it's
gonna be Marlon Mac and Jordan Wilkins
and we're gonna play inside out and I
just I really like the Colts it's a team
that I think knows what they're doing
right now and can protect the passer
versus a team that I don't know if I'm
getting Brock Osweiler or Ryan Tannehill
but I don't like their defense I don't
like their offense and I like the Colts
here to keep this magic roll yeah I
think we're getting tannenhill pretty
much for sure if I remember reading
correctly this morning and he might not
be a hundred percent but he's certainly
good enough to play was the statement I
heard out of the Miami Dolphins and my
Defensive Rookie of the Year Darius
Leonard it's gonna be running all over
the place
he is fun to watch alright so you so I
liked that you wanted to bet more on the
indie and I actually bet it more on
indie yeah III do too you know yeah I
just think the the thing that scares me
but the Dolphins is I just think they're
tough and I'm betting that tannenhill
does play and they'll just keep it maybe
just close enough it scares me it just
scares me I have no faith in the Colts
defense I'm not gonna sit there and put
a lot of money on that unit alright so
the opposite of the Arizona Chargers
game where two teams got two more like
God really demoralized at the end and
they're gonna have a dogfight is this
game Pittsburgh at Denver Pittsburgh big
comeback against Jacksonville Denver big
comeback against the Los Angeles
chargers I could see this game being a
letdown game Sims how do you see it well
it's this is an interesting matchup
first of all I think the Denver defense
really matches up well with with the
Pittsburgh Steelers offense I mean they
can get pressure with the front four
they can do things on the back end
creatively they can blitz and leave
their guys man-to-man enough to confuse
Big Ben and company and make life
interesting on the Pittsburgh defense so
I look at that and go man that that's a
pretty damn good matchup right there it
really is I guess I worry about Denver
as we know is their past I mean their
run defense has not been great this year
and you know I like Pittsburgh's old
line it's really good they don't try to
do a whole lot of different stuff in the
run game
you know they maybe have one or two
wrinkles but for the most part it's
inside outside zone and verse these
athletic fronts like we saw with
Jacksonville last week and they'll see
the Denver this week I guess I just
don't want to put a whole lot of stock
into thinking that their run game will
take off it's just a question mark I
would say I guess for me in this game
I'm not quite sure about that part of
the matchup now on the other side of the
ball you know the Denver offense Case
Keenum aggressive Philip Lindsey
explosive the Steelers defense has been
one of the more impressive units in
football over the last six or seven
weeks and I think the big thing is for
me is their front for
has been dominant at times I mean Dupree
and JJ Watt have been awesome Cameron
Hayward's been great you know a Lulu has
been good Stefan to it when he's healthy
a course is really good but what they've
done in the back end I think is where it
really separates them I mean they're not
like reinventing the wheel left go with
what they do on defense but the one
thing is they disguise well they make
coverages look the same and they have a
creative blitz or two or wrinkles to
their coverages on every in an every
week faces that I think it's really kind
of exciting and I give them a lot of
credit for kind of fixing those things
on that side of the ball I think this is
a close football game I mean down to the
wire or type of football game but I'm
gonna go with the team that has the
better quarterback and the better team
in general and I'm gonna go with the
Steelers winning the game 26 to 23 which
is a push but I'm gonna put my hundred
dollars on the Steelers if you make me
put my money anywhere I'm going with Big
Ben and company against the Broncos in
Denver so Steelers are four oh and one
on the road this year Denver in November
hasn't been the same since 2016 in
November home games there Owen four so
Denver is a sure bet when they're home
in September November teams are kind of
well conditioned and figure it out
Denver is as you said 27 versus the the
run on defense to your credit you said
before the year the Pittsburgh defense
was gonna be great they are top 10
against the run and the past right now
they even with all those big issues the
Tampa Bay game early some of their big
point totals it's completely different
right now Big Ben is 2 & 4 in his career
in Denver lost three straight last game
was in the 2016 playoffs when they lost
that was was that Denver's Super Bowl
run ebo and Big Ben was really hurt in
1926
oh no 2016 was the last time yes no 27
what 2016 will 2016 yes that was the
year Denver won the Super Bowl yes so
they beat Pittsburgh and then they beat
new Eli off
all right so I guess what I picked a
push to I picked 21 18 I think both
offenses are a little bit stagnant in
this one and I see Pittsburgh winning
this game 21 to 18 I two sided with
Pittsburgh and I am putting $50 on
Pittsburgh and I I just I don't I don't
I haven't seen it at a James Connor the
last two weeks well yeah I hear yeah
well you know again that Jacksonville
defense is still really good yeah and I
don't even remember what his stats were
against the Carolina Panthers but they
didn't need him so it didn't matter no
you know it's still there it certainly
is I will be I mean we've seen Denver
they've had their issue stopping the run
in games this year but that's gonna be
the case it will be the key if we can
can can they slow that down and make
Pittsburgh one-dimensional to where they
have to throw the ball in that loud
environment it is a home-field advantage
there in Denver but like you I'm just
going with a better quarterback and a
better team yeah I just have more faith
in Pittsburgh and I think Denver's gonna
start flaming out all right yeah Sunday
night
rematch of week two when it was Green
Bay taking on you still got me I'm here
I'm here here's what got me I do I hear
you okay sorry I hit Siri because
everybody needs Syrian though you never
freaking use Siri okay anyway rematch a
week to when the tie when Kirk Cousins
was amazing and Aaron Rodgers was
hobbled and they probably could have won
by more Minnesota is favored by three
and a half at home Sunday Night Football
everyone's questioning Green Bay
everybody's questioning Minnesota both
quarterbacks offensive coordinators all
that stuff where are you going in this
one yeah I mean I think this is gonna be
a really close football game I'll say
that right off the bat you know I think
you know the really the big thing here
for me that scares me more than in years
past with the Green Bay Packers is Green
Bay and the reason they won't make the
playoffs and the reason Aaron Rodgers
can't make as much magic happen
sometimes in the fourth quarters this
year as compared to others they can't
pass protect like they could
years passed they really can't and this
Vikings defense is still really really
good it's not quite as good as last year
but we know the secondary talent their
ability to rush the passer I think has
been better this year than it was last
year just as a pure front for at least
in my opinion yeah you hear me yeah
Anthony bars back to Anthony bar is back
right exactly so that's a big thing I
look at you know I just don't think the
Packers offense is diverse enough and
creative enough to really expose
anything from Minnesota I think this is
a tough matchup for this Green Bay
offense and then when I flip it around
hey I think this is a tough matchup for
Minnesota's offense - I mean Minnesota
you know they don't pass protect as well
they haven't they don't run the ball
nearly as well as they did last year I
mean last year they were one of the best
running teams in football if memory
serves me correct this year I think
they're our 27th and football so before
everybody wants to start blaming Kirk
Cousins there's a lot more issues at
hand here than just Kirk Cousins that's
the easy lazy thing to do if everyone
just points at Kirk Cousins goes he's
the issue no the issue is their
offensive line if you watched on Monday
Night Football it's not as dominant
Akeem Hicks and cool Mack whoop their
ass at certain points of that football
game up front and they can't run the
ball so then it's really it's more on
Kirk Cousins shoulders to make big plays
in the passing game I think though at
the end of the day the fact that it's at
home on that surface the issues I talked
about with the Packers o-line the
Packers defense hey it's it's a
formidable unit there's no doubt about
that but they will play some man-to-man
and give you chances to make plays in
the pass game like we saw Kirk Cousins
do in the fourth quarter of their first
matchup so I am picking the Vikings to
win the game
27:24 left go but I'm betting $50.00 on
the Packers
I think they keep it within three points
but only betting $50 because I'm scared
of Aaron Rodgers I guess more than
anything that's what I'm really scared
of
so I had the Vikings scoring 27 points
as well I think the Packers are Owen
five on the road this year if you go
back to last year there Owen seven the
Vikings are for one and one against
Green Bay in their last six games and I
think Zimmer has a pretty good bead on
this Green Bay offense I also think that
the weakness of Minnesota's offense is
that interior offensive line and Mike
Daniels and Kenny Clark I don't think
are playing right so that means that
Kirk is going to have time and he's
gonna get some man-to-man and I while I
love gyre Alexander I think that Diggs
and Filan could get off in this game on
the other side of the ball I look at
Aaron Rodgers and I go man he's gonna be
pullin teeth to score on this so I don't
have the Packers scoring 24 I have them
scoring 20 and I will be betting the
amount of $50 on Minnesota and I think
that this is the nail in the coffin to
Green Bay season my Super Bowl pick
comes to an end I think the Eagles and
Packers seasons and this weekend yeah
I'm not gonna go as sore as the Eagles I
think the Eagles season's over
regardless I don't see how you make it
but I think they're gonna win but yeah I
hear you man I'm with you with those
packer thoughts you know to the Packers
run running defense hasn't been good all
year long anyways and now they have
those people banged up I just you know I
guess I question whether Minnesota is
actually good enough to capitalize and
Minnesota as I said I said a few minutes
ago I stand corrected last year they
were the seventh best run running
offense in football this year their 31st
so that's my question whether they can
take advantage of that look Minnesota
wasn't able to fix their interior
offensive line they just they kind of
you know they had some injuries them
draft picks didn't pan out and right now
it's not looking good all right so
Monday Night Football here's a deal a
lot of casinos do not have a line listed
because they are worried about Mariota
but the ones that do have it as Houston
- 6 in Houston Tennessee is coming off a
bludgeon
at the hands of the Indianapolis Colts
where their defensive coordinator Dean
Pease went to the hospital before the
game everything looks okay and their
quarterback gone banged up and their
defense got a Visser ated and then
Houston is coming off of a game in which
they barely beat Washington where they
knocked out the starting quarterback and
he really couldn't put the game away
whether it was interceptions by deshaun
Watson or just penalties that kept
drives going on for for Washington they
couldn't settle it but Houston favored
by six at home on Monday night Houston
has won now six games in a row and the
Titans are are battling in the AFC South
yeah I mean both good defenses there
multiple they do a lot of different
creative things in the back end they get
both got pretty good defensive fronts I
mean from that standpoint it's really an
even matchup I mean the big question
really in this more than anything is
just you know is of course the Tennessee
Titans offense yeah the Mariota factor
as far as where his health is and you
know are we gonna see the offense we saw
two weeks ago we're gonna see the
offense that lame neg last week against
the Annapolis Colts you know again I
don't know really what to think of
Tennessee's offense I know even though
they're their little win streak against
the Dallas Cowboys I didn't sit there
and go oh man they figured it out here
they really got it going you know so I
guess there's still question marks from
me on that side of the ball I just look
at it and go yeah the defenses are equal
but I'd go hmm I'm giving the advantage
to the Texans I think they got more
playmakers more studs on their front
seven and are just a better unit all
together I'd give the advantage that
Titans may be in coverage and things
like that but it's close but I think
overall the Texas front seven puts them
ahead in that conversation and then on
the offensive side of the ball hey both
teams can run the football
we know that the Texans are a little bit
better than the Titans run into football
but it's the passing game and my faith
into Shaun Watson I think that puts it
over the edge for the for the Houston
Texans and winning the football game for
me the problem is I'm betting $100 on
the Titans because I don't know if
Houston
can win by more than six points and
again there's coaching familiarity in
this game can begin with with Grable and
Dean Pease vert Bill O'Brien and Romeo
Crennel there's too many things too many
you know knowing of the guy across your
field that's what scares me a little bit
in the matchup I'm picking the Texas to
win the game 21 to 17 but I put $100 on
the Titans Titans have lost six in a row
in Houston and they're one in five
against the spread in those games but I
do agree with you the coaching staff
going to the rival will be very
interesting I look at this and I'm just
gonna keep it simple I what was your
score 21 17 Texans I have the Texans
winning 24 to 20 but I went against my
spread and I'm putting $50 on Houston
because with Mariota banged up and Dean
pieces health I just have a lot of
questions about what's going on there
right now I do not think that the Titans
are gonna be able to get any run game
going against this Texans offense and so
in in gabbert or a banged up Mariota and
I also really like the way the secondary
is playing for the Texans I don't see
the big Corey Davis throws happening I
don't really see Jenny Smith getting off
the other side I will say this man I do
not have a lot of faith in the Texans
offense right now it's just it's just so
reliant on DeAndre Hopkins and I think
all of those titans corners are gonna be
able to kind of make that really hard on
them I just think in the end that I kind
of see a Texan score happening here on
defense that I'm not factoring in and I
I really I look I have the tech since
winning 24 20 but I'm only putting $50
on the cover let me go over we agreed on
10 Sims we disagreed on 5 the
disagreements I am putting 50 on New
Orleans you are putting a hundred on
Atlanta with the 13 point spread so it's
a 150 dollar disagreement for us right
there Jacksonville Buffalo you're
putting $100 on Jacksonville - three in
Buffalo I'm putting 50 that's another
150 point disagreement in that game
Oakland Baltimore Baltimore favored by
ten and a half you are putting 50 on
Oakland I am putting a hundred and fifty
on Baltimore a two hundred dollar
disagreement in that game what just wow
we are our little disagreements are
gonna be big swings they always are
Green Bay Minnesota I have $50 on
Minnesota if the cover of the three and
a half you are doing $50 on Green Bay
that is a $100 swing and then Tennessee
Houston you are doing a hundred on
Tennessee I'm doing $50 on Houston
that's a 150 dollar swing are big bets
you were biggest bet of the week is $300
on Washington I put a hundred and fifty
dollars on that so that could be a
hundred and fifty dollar swing if
Washington wins my big bets I have a big
bet on Baltimore that's why it's a huge
swing right there because you did
Oakland I have $300 on New England you
have a hundred so that could be plus 200
in my book and then we also have Indy
I'm going 300 you're going 100 so I
could make up $400 even if you get New
England in Indianapolis right so we do
have some disagreements in the betting
in those games which could cover up some
of the disagreements that we have but
again 10 agreements five disagreements I
had to make my locks the Thursday night
games so my locks for Thursday are going
to be Chicago Washington and New Orleans
if I had to do locks that incorporated
other games that were Sunday I would
have done Baltimore New England and Indy
granted they are bigger spreads but I
just think those teams are gonna cover
Simms are you ready for guaranteed to
lose oh yeah I'm ready alright so last
week how did Simms do and guaranteed to
lose I don't have that in front of me
right now I know that it was closed at a
few games flipped so if federic wants to
get into my ears same she went three in
two again so back-to-back three and two
weeks
where are we gonna start off you you
lost you one Jaguars Washington in
Philadelphia
last week because you had the Saints and
you lost I don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on I want Lions and Broncos God
you got you got you got you those were
your losers okay all right so let us do
you're guaranteed to lose this one is he
right here yes so you had the Jaguars
Washington the Eagles losing they did
and you had the Lions at Broncos losing
and they won okay good I just had a tell
we forget guaranteed two losses flipped
I don't know what your teams are so I
can't do good introductions your first
team guaranteed to lose is who oh well
whom will be losing on Thanksgiving
night sorry no Turkey for you Atlanta
Falcons you're gonna lose on
Thanksgiving night sorry there's no way
you're gonna beat the same since the
hottest team in the sport their offense
is indefensible and Falcons your defense
is not very good and you're in deep
trouble no stuffing for you I'm gonna
take a chance is your next loser your
fit your former coach oh you know it
let's go I don't like Raiders when they
have to travel east in this Baltimore
Ravens team I think they've found
something in Lamar Jackson's Raiders you
might play tough for a little while but
you ain't gonna win my momma said so
Dirty Diana sim said sorry Johnny G you
lose this Sunday take another risk here
it sounds like you're next guaranteed to
lose team he's in the Big Apple oh I
like it that we think the same let's do
it together J ETS News yep New England
and Tommy are gonna be angry about their
last performance they've had two weeks
to prepare and quite simply they're just
better they're in another class of
franchise than the Jets sorry New York
bad weekend for you the Patriots win the
Jets lose take another risk here I'm
gonna say your fourth team guaranteed to
lose
includes the Rosenwald that's left
ghosts favorite player in the NFL he
keeps betting on them on a weekly basis
but they will lose whether let go pick
them to win or not sorry the Chargers
are just too talented they won't blow
this one this week I like the Cardinals
they're heading in the right direction
but let's not be prisoners of the moment
the Chargers are still one of the best
teams in this board they win this game
SIA Arizona I'm just realizing this
right now do you know how good it is to
bet on Arizona 1 2 3 4 5 their they've
covered five games this year so one of
the best teams the NFL to bet on just a
little nugget there for you
I'm gonna guess last team guaranteed to
lose what now you got it you've been all
over it who is it who's it gonna be
I think it's Miami you know it let go
yes yeah there's no way they're going up
to Indianapolis right now you can't
touch Andrew Luck and when Andrew Luck
when he doesn't have time as a
quarterback he's dangerous as hell so
let alone now he can bake a cake in fact
he can cook a turkey some stuffing and
some mash potatoes the Colts are gonna
lose you know I mean the Colts are gonna
win sorry I'm not used to doing this for
my [ __ ] kitchen okay off today
Dolphins are gonna lose I guarantee it
awesome by the way just got the alert
carry on Johnson and Marvin Jones out
making us both feel better about our
Chicago Bears bet here's the deal thank
you guys so much is always Simpson left
go faithful you guys are incredible Sims
are you on TV at all this weekend no I
yes I am I'm doing a Sunday night
football pregame are you really alright
so be be ready for the memes Josh will
be taking pictures you guys take
pictures as well of him in the pregame
studio but for the rare time left go
memes will be available oh yeah
11 o'clock West Coast time 2 o'clock
Eastern the pregame show for the match
capital ones the match
Tiger Woods versus Phil Mickelson
I will be on set with Pat Perez samuel
l.jackson and charles barkley it is for
free the pregame show you can watch it
on the BR live app so you have to
download that bad boy and then it's
gonna be really available anywhere paper
review is sold if you want to buy it I
think it's like $19.99 I have a feeling
it's honestly gonna be really really fun
I know that any time those guys make a
side bet with each other they're coming
to me and Pat Perez to break it down
I got rehearsals all week but please
join me cuz I think I'm gonna try and
have a blast but 2 o'clock
Black Friday if you're in line to buy a
Tickle Me Elmo you can stream on your
phone if you're at home take a picture
of me I think Sims could be doing left
go memes
I mean fender because we do a left go
meme Sims doesn't know what a meme is
alright I'm gonna be watching man don't
screw it up I will I will try to do a
few screw-ups and then and be like the
only Phil I care about is the big [ __ ]
so we'll see how it goes alright for
Sims Oh Danielle just so you know she's
sitting here she saw the Instagram she
said she really liked how you made the
golfers face off oh thank you thank you
thank you did she like my velvet maroon
blazer that would he picked out would
you like his velvet maroon blazer that
he was wearing did you notice that she
can't say she did she wasn't looking
that closely at you man it's time we're
still in the shower
alright I'll check out the Instagram the
outfits fire I'm killing it for Sims in
Tahoe me ventric would say good evening
and the lef koe man holla holla holla
guys Happy Thanksgiving
we are thankful for you guys really more
than anything and all the support you
guys have given us over the years enjoy
and we will holler at you later
[Music]
you